vous satisfait des deux premières années
du mandat d' emmanuel macron ils ne sont
pas très enthousiastes ils se répondent
oui à 25% seulement et non à 75 % pour
françois bellamy qui est tête de liste
des républicains aux européennes ces
deux années sont surtout deux années
d'occasions perdues on écoute ce qu'il
disait sur ces news ce matin bons
sentiments si vous me le demandez sur
ces deux ans et qu'on a perdu beaucoup
de temps dans une conjoncture économique
qui était plutôt favorable avec cette
dynamique que le président de la
république avait derrière lui je crois
qu'il aurait pu faire des réformes très
structurante pour tenter de proposer un
cap pour l'avenir de notre pays de nous
redonner confiance et malheureusement
rien de tout cela n'a eu lieu
et voil son fils au tac que pensez-vous
des bilans des manuels macron alors je
serais peut-être pas aussi sévère que
françois-xavier bellamy rien n'a pas eu
lieu
mais enfin vous voyez si vous voyez
quelque chose a eu lieu voilà exactement
mais effectivement c'est difficile de
tirer un bilan absolument serein de ces
de ses deux premières années
alors peut-être pour donner quelques
pistes un des raisons pour lesquelles
pour lesquels c'est le cas c'est que je
crois que le maquereau nisme c'était
vraiment une synthèse alors ça a voulu
être une synthèse libéral donc entre un
libéralisme économique
un libéralisme culturel je crois que ce
n'est pas un libéralisme politique et
que c'est déjà une première
contradiction alors voilà alors je pense
qu effectivement culturellement il ya
des éléments très libéraux on le voit
bien avec les lois avec la réflexion sur
la gpa etc j'aimerais encore abouti
absolument sur le plan économique on
comprend bien que les réformes sont
plutôt libérale je pense que sur le plan
politique le maquereau nice me reste une
forme de césarisme plébiscitaire j'en
suis persuadé depuis longtemps et j'ai
d'ailleurs j'avais fait une petite
chronique donc au moment de la campagne
manuel maintenant que saper un empereur
immédiatement qui faisait référence de
manière admirative au livre de marin de
viry
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
erreur fondamentale chez chez emmanuel
macron qui est que où on a parlé d'une
présidence jupitérienne moi j'aime pas
du tout ce terme de jupiter en revanche
je crois qu'il y avait eu une intuition
et son intuition c'était qu'il ya une
espèce de refouler en france et que ce
refoulé c'est un refoulé politique c'est
à dire qu'on a eus je ne suis pas du
tout bonapartiste 1 mais il ya eu 20 ans
de bonapartisme réussi en fait
économiquement plutôt libéral plutôt
prospère et je crois qu'il a eu des
intuitions qui se rapprochait ça c'est à
dire du social et et du de l'autoritaire
du jupitérien disons est il là il a en
réalité abandonner assez rapidement le
côté jupitérien et surtout il a commis
des erreurs parce qu'on n'est pas dans
une société du 19e siècle et je pense
effectivement que son bilan est
difficile aujourd'hui à tony alors
maintenant pour être un petit peu plus
précise je crois qu'il a aussi s'est
appuyé sur quelque chose qui est pas du
tout inquiet qui est pas du tout alors
qu'il est pas du tout de l'ordre du
césarisme qui est de l'ordre de 2
cette espèce de fracture entre les
élites et finalement le peuple au sens
au sens large qui existaient bien avant
lui mais que cette sécession des élites
il en a eu l'intuition mais que le
problème c'est qu'il a incarné tellement
qu'aujourd'hui elle lui revient
véritablement en boomerang
d'accord aussi aussi votre bas il ya les
faits il ya le sens bon les fesses et
sur les grands dossiers on va dire le
déficit structurel
on progresse très lentement il suffit de
voir les courbes de projection qui sont
par définition très très optimiste même
même très optimiste on progresse très
lentement sur le marché du travail est
bon quelque chose être une réforme de
fait n'est pas énormément sur l'
équilibre du financement du système
social là aussi il ya eu encore quelques
quelques quelques petites choses qui ont
qui ont été avancées mais pas non plus à
la hauteur des enjeux pour l'instant en
tout cas depuis deux ans qu'il est là
sur la question des structures sociales
disons qu'ils fondent un peu
la république sur l'éducation et la
famille je mets la famille dans les
structures sociales bon sur l'éducation
ça progresse dans un sens qui et je
dirai ambiguë en fait c'est à dire qu'on
ne voit pas véritablement la
reconstruction d'une école républicaine
intégratrice telle que l a souhaité tous
de motion droite ne voit pas on voit
effectivement des discours élitiste on
voit des discours sur l'effort on voit
des discours sur l'intégration
républicaine mais en même temps la
machine est tellement énorme à faire
bouger qu'elle bouge très peu de fatma
et sur la famille a le bougisme sociétal
habituel des gouvernements ou des
espaces de progressisme rapide à peu
près ce bouton dans lesquels on peut
dire pma gpa etc et axa apparaît dans la
loi c'est formidable sur le plan des
souverainetés du rayonnement
international bas je laisserai les
géopoliticiens autour de cette table
faire le milan mais enfin je suis pas
sûr que l'on pèse d'un poids beaucoup
plus considérable en europe depuis que
qu'emmanuel macro est là et puis bon
donc ça c'est bilan sur les fêtes on va
dire un jeu je vais je vais aller vite
sur le sens si on considère qu'un mobile
ans et un bilan dans lequel on a
beaucoup dépensé d'énergie pour aller
très très lentement vers une sorte de
normalisation anglo saxon c'est un bon
bilan
si on considère que ce sens là n'est pas
le bon sens pour la société française
c'est un mauvais bilan
il est allé surtout dans un sens qui est
au fond un sens de l'ibf a un sens dans
lequel ce qu'on arrive à lire c'est la
libéralisation sur des principes
anglo saxons tels que ils se déploient
internationalement si on arrive à le
lire mais par contre sur la partie sur
laquelle il fait des espèces de percer
intellectuel assez étrange c'est à dire
finalement qu'est-ce que la france
qu'est ce que notre identité ce que
souhaite une identité en mouvement
excuse qui tarde à signer comment on s'y
prend etc
il est à ses débuts le il est assez
nébuleux il a beaucoup de mal en réalité
à incarner parce qu'une vision
probablement parce que il n'a pas de
vision il a à la place de la vision il a
une méthode une méthode consiste à faire
parler tout le monde à ouvrir les débats
et a tranché à la fin mai a tranché quoi
on ne le sait pas d'avancé parce qu'il
n'a pas de prévisions si jusqu'à la
france donc c'est comment dirais-je
heureusement qu'il ya la cia les
institutions de la vème république pour
comment dirais-je le tenir en place
parce que c'est pas lui qui tient les
institutions c'est des institutions
tiennent d'une certaine façon parce que
ça manque de sens voilà très clairement
d'accord je vais finir le tour de table
vous la vie dans global j'avais
travaillé pour le compte de la fondation
jean jaurès que vous citiez d'auteur à
faire l'inventaire des années hollande
mais on avait prudemment attendu que le
quinquennat soit terminé et d'observer
par ailleurs qu'il n'avait pas été en
situation de se représenter à l'issue de
son propre quinquennat ça prouvait que
les français considéraient que son bilan
n'était pas suffisamment positif pour le
laisser seul loisir là alors macron
c'est un peu tôt au bout de deux ans
évidemment pour parler de bilan mais il
ya une première façon de poser la
question qui est de se dire ce qu'il a
fait depuis deux ans est il conforme à
ce qu'il avait annoncé qu'il ferait bien
que pour l'instant est ce qu'il est en
train de suivre de façon un peu
méthodique ce qui était son programme et
le fait-il j'ai le sentiment que oui
c'est vrai que il n'a dupé a à peu près
personne et qu'au contraire ce qui lui a
été reprochée et ce qui a constitué un
des ferments du mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'est sa politique fiscale pour
laquelle il avait pourtant affiché la
couleur de façon extrêmement clair
pendant la présidentielle donc il
déroule depuis deux ans sa volonté de
réforme s'est volonté de sa volonté de
réforme il avait incarné cette volonté
réformatrice
avec roland quelque chose qui lui
revient aujourd'hui en boomerang dans la
campagne de 2010 est où il avait
expliqué que avec une tonalité un peu
anti système
je ne mets pas du côté des populistes
mais il avait lui-même entraîné cette
petite musique du le système a
dysfonctionné depuis 30 ans et il est
temps de refermer cette parenthèse là
qui est une part
tess d'immobilisme de renoncement et
c'est dans la communication
gouvernementale en particulier au début
du quinquennat
on a beaucoup joué de cette petite
musique là on réforme enfin la sncf
qu'on avait pas réformé depuis toujours
on réforme enfin le code du travail
qu'on n'avait pas réussi à réformer en
particulier ceux hollande avec la loi
travail etc etc
donc de ce point de vue là il fait ce
qu'il avait annoncé qu'il ferait il
s'est plutôt on devrait plutôt s'en
réjouir sauf que c'est ce qui a mis les
français quand même dans la rue il y à
quelques six mois et donc dans le bilan
il ya aussi le fait qu' il se trouve
confronté à un mouvement social inédit
comme aucun de ses prédécesseurs varie
donc là on a fait l'impact des gilet
jaune avant ça christophe de rock votre
bilan de mi-mandat donc j'existe
l'histoire étaient dix dont c'est vrai
que à peu près d'accra et tout ce qui a
été dit il ya quand même quelques îles
mais ça mérite ni excès d'honneur ni
excès d'indignité comme on le comme on
dit moi je serai j'aime beaucoup cette
comparaison avec un certain bonapartisme
on parle du deuxième empire en tête du
second temple et il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom c'est un saint
simoniens en fait emmanuel macron c'est
pas un libéral ça on peut le démontrer
par a plus b d'ailleurs je veux signal
ça a été très peu relevé dans les
commentaires dans sa conférence de
presse il a dit je suis saint simoniens
il a dit voilà une observation saint
simonienne et je crois que si on part
avec ces deux clés on comprend beaucoup
plus ce personnage l'entourage des
nominations la politique etc
maintenant ça c'est le sens vous
reparler comme martin jerry maintenant
sur les faits c'est quand même là je
suis un petit peu plus d'accord avec
françois-xavier bennani c'est quand même
pas énorme tout ça on va toujours on va
toujours moins bien que les autres
le voir ça de dire notre déficit public
et supérieur
il se il diminue moins vite il va le
repartir à la hausse l'année prochaine
et comme vous disiez il ya eu problème
gilet jaune
et qu'est-ce que faye madeleine macro
maintenant moi j'ai quand même bien
l'impression quand on écoute le contenu
de ce qu'il propose
il est reparti départ tiberi alors c'est
la grande question que je voulais vous
poser à tous vous vous considérez qu'il
n'est pas libérale mais en tout cas on
peut peut-être reconnaître que jusqu'à
présent jusqu'à
jusqu au phénomène des gilet jaune je
veux pas dire crise parce qu'on ne
connaît pas la fin donc au phénomène des
gilet jaune
il avait une politique qui s'affichera
en tout cas pro entreprises je sollicite
de l'offre alors l'alluré parti d'alors
matic de la demande alors la question
c'est voilà est-ce que c'est son
tournant de 83 à lui est ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il a sacrifié le
redressement de notre compétitivité pour
que ce soient parfaitement claires sur
l'autel du pouvoir d'achat de la
distribution immédiate de pouvoir
d'achat
oui alors juste sur l'ex sur la question
du saint simonisme ça c'est très
intéressant il est vous dites il est
saint simoniens il y avait 1 mondiale
lundi
oui c'est lui qui vous le dit parce
qu'il le dinard ille leur transfert aux
provinces et les grillades
c'est à dire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les pois les premiers rangs de
la société sont occupées par les
industriels c'est ça c'est une question
de dignité dans la société il ya un
magnifique pamphlet de stendhal qui
s'appelle d'un nouveau complot contre
les industriels qui est un pamphlet anti
saint simoniens dans lequel stendhal dit
quoi ça ne passera jamais en france ça
ne passera jamais en france
en france on admirera toujours la
noblesse qu'est ce que la noblesse c'est
de mettre au dessus de soi son propre
intérêt qu'est ce que le saint simonisme
ces deux mètres au sommet de la société
l'intérêt du de l'entrepreneur et c'est
cette espèce de cette espèce de comment
dirais-je de lignes de fracture
culturelle qui existe qui existait et
que nous peyrefitte avait a parfaitement
analysé alors lui est plutôt souvent
les cultures religieuses à faire mais
c'est fondamental c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas avoir deux présidents de la
république française qui incarne
simplement le discours de la production
de l'entreprise que ce sont de
l'entreprise en mettant en fabriquant
une espèce de transe en danse
entrepreneuriale parce que c'est pas si
des discussions chez les as a service je
laisse à siemens et jassim ans et pas
seulement les chefs d'entreprise c'est
beaucoup plus bas sinon j'aimerais quand
même des changements non retour à la
normale ça veut dire qu'il n'était pas
ça normal à la normale française c'est à
dire que tout ce qui m'est arrivé en
france vous savez qu'on parle de
libéralisme dès qu'on n'est pas ultra
étatiste le mot sort immédiatement et
bien on ne retrouve finalement revient
une gestion au jour le jour
il a dit lui-même il ya dit ce que je
prends donne d'une main je reprendrai de
l'autre il l'a dit pendant le grand
débat autrement dit ce que j'ai pris je
donnais aux particuliers je le reprends
aux entreprises
après avoir fait l inverse c'est à dire
que je crois véritablement posons la
question carrément je pense
véritablement que sur le fond le
quinquennat est terminée au sens de son
sang c'est à dire que les grandes
réformes je pense aux retraites je pense
à l'assurance chômage
je pense à la fonction publique ils
n'auront pas tous en fuite
ce qui a marqué le début du quinquennat
c'est moi en fait une politique de
l'offre qui se distinguait de la
précédente
on a beaucoup reproché à françois
hollande d'avoir mené lui-même une
politique de l'offre
on peut la critiquer avec macro
absolument donc de ce point de vue là
mâcon c'est plutôt situés dans la
continuité de françois hollande en
suspens en mimant et en mimant de faire
le contraire mais il était quand même
dans la continuité de ce qui se passait
avant non ce qui a marqué les esprits et
ce qui a tranché effectivement c'est la
politique fiscale qui l'a mise en place
alors il avait annoncé la couleur encore
une fois mais ceux qui aujourd'hui lui
revenir au boomerang quand même c'est
cette politique fiscale dont il avait
fait une condition de notre attractivité
économique
donc je ne juge même pas en fait la
politique fiscale en tant que tel mais
il y avait une promesse d'efficacité
dans le maquereau nisme savez une
promesse de renouvellement il y avait
une promesse d'efficacité cette
politique fiscale il a arrêté
pour financer les 11 milliards du
premier train de mesures qu'il avait
annoncées
il a reporté jeudi la poursuite de la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés il a
pas où il a quand même fait il a fait
voter il a quand même s'est il a quand
même fait sa réforme fiscale
du côté des entreprises et il a fait sa
réforme de liesse f il n'a pas supprimé
lisf mais il a transformé lisf de telle
façon que ce qui lui est reproché par
une partie de l'opinion depuis deux ans
c'est cette injustice fiscale mais sans
même aller sur la question de la justice
fiscale finit son programme propre
repreneur est allé en tout cas non mais
n'hésite pas en tout cas sur ce sont
même allés sur le terrain de l'injustice
fiscale de ce procès qui lui est fait
encore une fois sa politique fiscale
était justifiée par une volonté
d'efficacité une recherche d'efficacité
économique notre activité hors de ce
point de vue là hollande a perdu à cause
du chômage qu'il n'a pas réussi dont il
n'a pas réussi à inverser la courbe
suffisamment tôt et suffisamment fort on
observe que en matière de croissance et
en matière de baisse du chômage
malheureusement à ce stade les résultats
ne sont pas là notre excellent collègue
marc landré a publié un article il ya
une dizaine de jours je crois sur sur
les créations d'emploi soit hollande s
ou maquereau en démontrant que de ce
point de vue là on était dans une forme
de contre performance en dépit de cette
politique pro business ce que je voulais
juste rajouter c'est qu'on est à deux
ans donc c'est difficile de faire un
bilan absolument de ses réformes
économiques
moi ce que je sais sur quoi je voulais
insister tout à l'heure en disant qu'il
n'était pas libéral politiquement je dis
bien c'est que je pense vraiment que
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a une vision
un peu gaullienne si on peut dire qui
est d'ailleurs considéré comme co
maintient appartenant d'une certaine
manière à cette droite un peu
plébiscitaire de gaulle un pandraud est
ce que je voulais souligner également
c'est que en fait le je crois comme
mâcon emmanuel ma course s'est rendu
compte que finalement il y avait une
forme de sécession entre les élites et
le peuple il s'est rendu compte que lui
il représentait d'une certaine manière
cette session et je crois qu'il va quand
même un petit peu à canossa en disant
ben je vais faire un effort pour
résorber cette fracture
sauf que c'est très compliqué de
résorber cette fracture ah oui c'est
très coûteux et puis surtout il a pris
entre la phase c'est finalement la crise
qui n'est pas seulement la sienne
d'ailleurs mis la prise de plein fouet
on évoque et rapidement les réformes à
venir dans la majorité beaucoup de gens
sont persuadés que le résultat des
européennes qui ont lieu je le rappelle
le 26 mai allaient voter aura un impact
sur sa la capacité des manuels macron a
continué d'appliquer son programme
et puis on s'inquiète des difficultés de
nathalie l'oiseau qui est la tête de
liste la république en marche qui est
talonné même dépasser dans certains
sondages par la liste du rassemblement
national d'où la question que nous avons
posée à nos internautes
emmanuel macron doit-il intervenir dans
la campagne d